thank God I didn't have a baby with a
blue man like a Blue Man
Group they have to wear all the makeup
in case one gets hurt they do not have
to wear them no she's in no Broadway
standing don't listen to
her no they're standing there's always
four blue men in full just praying that
one of them breaks their
ankle you I'm telling you the show must
go on Esther I think I know how show is
works you think they're just out there
winging it with four men in makeup
there's no time you know how long it
takes to get B up looks really hard yeah
so they're just there's four guys that
365 days a year Put on Full makeup and
just sit there waiting dated wait when
I've like studied your whole history I
don't remember this this is new
information there's a couple there's a
couple blind spots even I won't
acknowledge eser